the plat of generic three has been in
the air for quite some time but now
another detail that will certainly
please many fans of action-packed cinema
entertainment has been announced the
third part of the series will be the
longest so far with the running time of
131 minutes the popular body count will
also be significantly higher in part
three that in the two predecessors the
story is about John wick who is supposed
to deal with the fact that he's now
wanted by his contract killer colleagues
for a bounty of 40 million dollars due
to a murder committed without permission
John wick 3 will be shown in cinemas on
May 17th 2019 and afterwards the
spin-off series the Continental will
continue to focus on the time before the
first John wick film although Avengers
and Game will not be released in the
u.s. for five days many spoilers have
been adding up over the last part of the
Avengers saga since last week
for example a four-minute video showing
different key scenes of the film was
published on the Internet
the video not only anticipates a few
gags but also clarifies important
questions and fan theories that
currently exist on relevant Internet
platforms such as reddit since there are
many trolls on the internet who want to
spoil the movie for the fans it is not
advisable to follow too much gossip
around the New Avengers movie even if
that is difficult in view of the
gigantic hype Avengers and game will be
released next Friday April 26 in the US
many fans are currently expressing their
outrage that Johnny Depp will still play
the role of Gellert Grindelwald in the
upcoming third part of the fantastic
beasts series
the reason for this is a complaint by
Depp's ex-wife Amber Heard who accuses
him of multiple physical abuse after Deb
has filed a libel action against her the
legal dispute between the two ex
bowser's has now been going on for about
three years what continues to discomfort
the fans is a report by the New York
Times Magazine page 6 which is said to
have found out that Warner is allegedly
going crazy about the case one insider
is quoted as saying executives at Warner
Brothers are wondering how to deal with
the backlash of the Deaf matter on the
Harry Potter franchise high level female
executives at the studio
extremely worried about working with Deb
and the message is sense to the public
it's also important to know that Harry
Potter creator JK Rowling has been
behind Depp in the past so Warner
doesn't seem to really know how to
decide in the case because one way or
another they'll upset many fans one can
only hope that soon there will be
clarity in the House of Warner by the
way fantastic these three will be
released in early 2021 after Amazon
recently announced that there would be a
lot of the ring series with the hefty 1
billion US dollar budget many fans of
the film series were quiet over the moon
now it became known among other things
that instead of the New Zealand
landscape the beautiful Scottish
landscape is now to serve as a set for
the new series in addition it seems
likely that production will even start
this summer after all the Lord of the
Ring officials have announced a release
date in 2021 unlike in the film's the
Lord of the Rings series focuses on the
age in which sovereign forged the rings
of power
the initial rumors that a serious could
also be about the story of the young
Aragorn are now most likely denied we
will also find out soon whether Peter
Jackson will again be the director and
producer of the new series fans of the
Star Wars universe can look forward to
new intergalactic adventures in an
interview with MTV last week Lucas film
director Kathleen Kennedy confirmed that
they are currently working on a project
on Star Wars Knights of the Old Republic
she didn't want to reveal exactly what
she meant by that so whether the new
project would be a video game a serious
or even a film fans are currently
looking forward to the upcoming US
release of Star Wars Episode nine on
December 20th which is actually said to
be the last movie of the Star Wars saga
for quite some time however you can be
curious what Lucasfilm plans to do with
the Star Wars universe in the future
there are news from The Suicide Squad
universe since there are more and more
indications that the Suicide Squad won't
be a radical reboot of the first part
the gossip Factory about the cast is
working overtime
according to Variety none other than
wrestling legend John Cena is currently
in contract negotiations with director
James Gunn
the rule was actually meant for WWE
colleague dave bautista
who unfortunately can't be part of the
Suicide Squad anymore due to scheduling
reasons in addition variety announces
that idris elba will not take over the
role of that shot after all rich rural
he will play instead is known yet by the
way the Suicide Squad will be released
in August 2021 the film will he mean
Rhapsody is now among the hundred most
successful films of all time after the
film was awarded with astonishing four
Oscars at the Academy Awards and has
earned 900 million u.s. dollars
worldwide the film about Queen lead
singer freddie mercury's now in number
53 of the most successful films and
therefore even beats Harry Potter and
the Goblet of Fire
also ex-queen members Brian May and
Roger Taylor both will receive a
significant share of the revenues due to
their co-production
[Music]